so when i was a kid i used to sell
stereo equipment out of this trunk of my
car right
so i got a chance to go all over to
different areas and i said wow
i would ask questions i was always
curious i said why are values here in
new jersey so much cheaper than they are
equidistant from new york in the
opposite direction so i said maybe i
should buy something there so i bought
this
little condo there and two years later
it more than doubled in value
and uh by the time i was 25 i had
invested in like 20 different properties
because i thought that that was the way
to go
barry that same place you bought at 68
000 what is it worth today
if i were to guess i'd probably say
probably 400 500
400 500 000 wow 60 to 4 500 000
so long term play with real estate if
you buy and hold you're going to be all
right
population population's going up so you
know it's and it's tough to build we
could talk about how tough it is to
build right now
how tough it is to build right now
because you cannot find the guys that
are actually doing the work for you yeah
well you know labor is tough uh that's a
big that's a big one that people don't
really think about you know there's
problems with that that we can get into
with the
with the pandemic unemployment
assistance 9.3 million jobs available we
can't fill them i mean really
if you incent people to stay home
they're going to stay home now there's a
portion of the population that have to
worry about child care so of course
but there's a lot of people that hey
look you can't blame them if i'm going
to make more money if i want to make 18
an hour to stay home i'll make less than
that to work and work
has other expenses and is tough it's
going to be hard but a lot of soft costs
land's expensive when you think about it
if you construct
and the cost of your construction is
let's just say it's 150
bucks a square foot you want to build a
2 000 square foot home
you're already at 300 000 land
soft costs you're at 500 000 and you
haven't made any profit
and people are wondering why is there no
inventory for the demand of first-time
home buyers
it's because we can't supply the new
inventory people are not able to
to buy a home below half a million
dollars very easily or find a home below
a half a million dollars very easily
especially in jersey yeah
new york but in most in many places of
the country though it has gotten pretty
pricey
on new construction so you have to find
an older home an existing home
but those aren't coming up on the market
because somebody has to sell that which
means they now have to buy a much more
expensive home correct in a tight
inventory environment yeah then the
price
they just came out with the average
price of home officially is at 350 000
this is as of uh i think this article we
talked about last week kai
350 is the average price of home today
so i want to talk about that because
it's not the average actually it's the
median price and there's a big
difference there
and the media oftentimes messes this up
because what they'll say is that's an
increase of almost 25
year-over-year so they're saying real
estate's it's going to bubble because
it's up 25 that's not the case median
means that half the sales above it half
the sales below it no inventory on the
lower end it's down 35 percent in sales
because there's no inventory
homes over a million are up more than
200 percent over 100
over 750 180 percent increase
in how long and what time in the last
year okay so the median home price has
been skewed
much higher based upon the mix of sales
i got it actual appreciation
is 13 now we just got new numbers today
which i'm not privy to as of yet
but year over year it's about 13 it's
still hotter than we'd like okay but
it's not 25.
13 means a 300 000 house last year's 339
right now
it's it's exactly right yes correct yeah
i mean he's got a calculator yeah so so
you guys so okay so
so if we're looking at that being the
price so is today
a good time the whole thing let's stay
on what you just talked about which is
hard to kind of get the builders
who's taking the biggest hit right now
because when i talk to gas with gcs
and i say house business gc general
contract how's business oh man we
we're like we can't even we have you
guys six months 12 months like we got
com people want our business right now
who's winning right now who's losing
right now because of what's going on
with real estate well if you look at
some of the earnings from builders
they're skyrocketing right lanark just
came out with earnings and skyrocketing
so they're they're certainly um
in a very strong position even though
costs are higher
they've put in the contracts escalation
clauses and things like that that can
protect them
so people are buying homes for x amount
on the contract wind up paying more by
the time they go to closing
so i don't know if if it's a win because
you could also say somebody who
purchased a home a year ago they won too
right so and i think if you buy a home
today and if you don't do it
unwisely you will continue to be a
winner because i see real estate values
continuing to go higher
unwisely so people talk about a housing
bubble there is no housing bubble but
you could put yourself in a housing
bubble
if there's a home that's valued today
that the real value if you would get an
appraisal or an automated valuation
model and it's 400 000. the seller is
going for the moon they're going to put
it up there for
450. and if you get emotional in your
transaction
you start competing against a couple of
people and you pay 525 for a home that's
worth 400
you put yourself in your own housing
bubble there's not a housing bubble but
you just bought unwisely
what's the alternative though there's
nothing in the market listen it's not
easy you have to be patient sometimes
you may have to move a little bit
further from a specific geographic area
that's tough to do if i'm tied to a job
i've been there for 12 years you're 100
right i'm not saying it's easy yeah i'm
saying that there are certainly many
challenges here
but you have to be able to so we created
this tool by the way patrick we created
a tool that will tell you
at what point in the future the home
that you are purchasing
above what it's purchased so yeah that
400 000 valued home that you purchased
let's say for 460. okay
which is pretty heavy above asking price
when in the future
will that home be worth 460. is it eight
months is it 24 months is it third
or is it eight years if it's eight years
maybe you should make no sense but
there's certain markets you will catch
up within a year or two you might say
okay i might be into that got it so i
guess the question like right now we
have a question here mark
shock who asks the question on twitter
he said my wife and i have down payments
saved and ready to buy we live in the
dfw metroplex and homes are selling 30
to 100
000 over asking price at times all cash
and no inspection
should we buy now or wait a year or two
will the market get better
better is relative terms so will it get
more expensive yeah it'll get more
expensive so
should you bite the bullet yeah you have
to just you have to really every home
is different there is no blanket result
because you cannot duplicate a home only
one homecoming
can you pull up his tweet out there so
we can see what he's keep doing so what
you want to try and do
is get the best advice that you can as
to what if i pay over
how long will it take me to catch up and
of the choices that are out there and
there may not be very many choices
but try to make the best decisions
possible be patient over the next 30 60
90 days because you'll be okay there but
two years from now that value is going
to be up
significantly kai can you go to go to
zillow.com matter of fact just go to
zillow.com
and go to uh uh uh i'd be i'd love to
know what mark's zip code is go to dfw
uh we could pull it up on our site we'd
have to get in go to dfw just with
dallas fort worth
okay this is the site that everybody has
access to so just kind of take a look at
this
foray for sale for sale and
go uh what is the range you run at the
top go close that x go to
price go to price and go from uh
300 now put 300 men to 500 000
okay to 500 000 yeah right there let's
take a look at what comes up
and then uh get the list uh that the
list comes
you literally put 300 so maybe change it
to 300 000.
i don't know what kind of house there
you go press done there you go okay all
right so then go on that 450 right there
for you that says 450 click on that
so this 450 thousand dollar house
beautiful one bedroom two bath
just a gorgeous house think about that
now go a little lower
it's been on the market for 263 days
okay click on that
click on the house you were on and just
go lower go lower on the right side
right there keep going lower lower lower
grab that mls number for a second
uh go one four four like a true crystal
ball champion yeah yeah yeah one
four four four four four four nine five
six five one all right i'm telling um i
know that i've got people watching this
so i
i got my boy office get that get that
mls number it's one
four four four nine five six five and if
you're listening put that in our our
system and let's see how long it'll take
for this home to get up there and what
it's worth today
keep going up keep going up so zillow
keep keep going up
a little bit higher keep going keep
going kai okay this was built check this
out
this was built in 1946 i don't even know
what house this is for 450 it's one
bedroom
two bathroom for 450 that's got to be
the land because
you don't understand this is not even in
a great area like this is this is
keep going down keep going don't be
talking trash about texas buddy
no i got a great appointment for addison
yes kai keep going lower okay here we go
so 2020 price price change 8.95
what 9.95 listed for sale
taxes on the property were paid tax
assessment look at that it was paid on
176 180 so it's gone down over the years
the tax assessment on it keep going
lower
keep going lower i mean at 450
i'm looking at a house like this this
has got to be like a five
acre property with a mini house on type
in dallas just get back don't even do
dfw just go to dallas
you know just do dallas and here pull
out that
well pull up the one for 4.99 right
there because that's a single pillar
either one of those it's four bedrooms
let's take a look at this now
so this is 22.56 that's a nice house
okay
four bedroom five bath 22.56
what it looks like lower chi okay right
there
491 just went into the market uh no tax
history available you're looking at 4.99
so this house
assuming this house uh does it show what
year was built
it looks like a new build looks like a
new built house i mean you got to know
like right now if you're in the market
you're middle america
newly built 2021 220 222 per square feet
okay
thank god it's got ac by the way because
you're going to need it in texas in
dallas
you're sitting there at a four out of
499 house
okay middle income family how much down
payment am i gonna need for that five
ten percent or can i do 100
financing you can do um today
today's 95 97 financing okay let's just
say 95
financing five percent on 500 is 25 000.
25 000
down which may not seem like a lot of
money it's a lot of money for people
that are making 70 grand a year not a
lot of people have twenty five thousand
dollars down payment just put up there
okay so you put 25 000 down your payment
on that's going to be what what's your
payment going to be on that give or take
is it fair to say your payment on a 500
000 bucks
2500 a month you're doing it at five
times i see what you're doing
so 2500 a month which is not bad and you
gotta put twenty five thousand dollars
down estimate a monthly payment
twenty seven four five hundred thousand
dollar house in
dallas texas okay yeah so you know
the the the challenge becomes the
challenge becomes some people now on the
flip side of it are saying
well you should buy realtors are saying
the complete opposite buy today because
money is so cheap don't worry about the
price of the house
buy it because interest rates are so low
i mean look what these bigger guys are
doing they're going buying five billion
dollars
of land and properties and they're
paying 25 percent above market prices
if they're doing it why shouldn't we do
it because money is so cheap what do you
say to that
i said yeah money is cheap now but it's
also money is cheap
which has helped boost prices up it's
like a lever you know money money goes
down in the cost
so that's going to help shut prices up
and escalate them the thing is is that
if you put yourself in a position that's
over your
over your means it becomes more
problematic for you because you want to
make sure you can still make those
payments and if you pay
much more for the house then you're able
to handle
what happens if you run into trouble
what happens if the price of that
whatever turbulence within that area
there are risks involved i do think
overall real estate values definitely go
up
and i'd suggest to people to try and
purchase that home but also one of the
things you'll see on there is how many
square feet the home
so that home was going for less than two
hundred dollars a square foot 222
222 okay so 220 a square foot
that home at that level compared to
other homes in your market
of similar style and see am i paying
much more per square foot than what the
market is bearing if you start thinking
about homes instead of the price
think about a price per square foot for
a comparable that's a good way to know
if you're doing that
very helpful so let me ask you barry so
let's just say let's just say top five
right okay for example if you're looking
for a spouse
if you're looking for a spouse number
one you have to be you have to be
physically attracted to them whatever
let's just say number two is
you got to be sharing the similar common
values and principles number three is
you know families got to get along
because you're marrying the family not
whatever number four is whatever you go
down the list
i know you have experience yeah many
people ask me these questions so if i'm
asking you
what are the top five markers for me to
look at would you put
price per square feet of the house
number one or what would you put out
number one well
you know you have to live there right so
while the economics
definitely are going to play a major
role i like the house
this is your home so does it fit for
your lifestyle that's the big revenue
let's go through it yeah so so is this
right we're all taking notes here all
right all good well good fit
top five is this fit for your home is
this fit for you is this something that
you're gonna be comfortable in fit for
you and your family and your family
what a timeline what timeline five years
three years you know this is an
interesting one so the average time
someone lives in a home if it's a first
home if it's your first home your
average time is three and a half years
it is a home that you is more not your
first home yeah it's over nine years
nine to ten years that is the typical
average time interesting
so so start at home three and a half
years yeah yeah second home
nine to 10 years yeah so listen when i
was doing mortgages right and i was
originating more like
relationships your first girlfriend's
three years if you marry somebody's ten
years so that's that's pretty good for
first year
so um so i uh
i i used to do mortgages not one at a
time what really changed my career is i
started doing two at a time i would say
okay we're gonna do this mortgage but
then
what are we gonna be doing that fits it
part of the puzzle in the next mortgage
and anybody who's taking out a mortgage
do not think one at a time think about
intertwining them because
timeline is the most important thing so
if you are online
if you're if you think that this home
will be right for your time horizon
then yeah the next thing that i would be
thinking about is
upside potential so what is this
market's
forecasted appreciation is this market
going to make me money because now that
we've got this is fits for me now let's
start making money right
if i'm buying a stock it's important
what i buy the stock for
but what's really important is what am i
going to sell it for because if i'm
going to
okay say take peter deal right does it
matter what
if he paid .01 cents or 0.02 cents okay
so um
he what we want to make sure is that
what we're doing is
giving ourselves the ability to make
money in the future not just
to pocket the money but so that we can
keep up and we can stay ahead of the
market so when we purchase the next home
we can at least keep what should be a
reasonable number for me to be happy
with so if i buy half a million dollar
house
what should my expectation be five ten
years down the line so for right now
the expectation that we're seeing is
approximately six percent per year
so that means that at six percent this
is where this is where people need to
understand
six percent might not sound very
exciting but it is because if you take a
home let's take a hundred thousand
dollar home i know you can't get a home
for a hundred but let's just
do the exercise a hundred thousand
dollar home you put ten percent down
that means you put ten thousand dollars
down that hundred thousand dollar home
if it appreciates eight percent
that's six percent sorry that means the
home made six
thousand dollars six thousand dollars
profit
on a ten thousand dollar investment is a
sixty percent rate of return
sure and if you were to take that home
and you were to say okay
at six percent appreciation if it is not
my first home
if i'm going to be there for 12 years or
something like that the home values
doubled
so that home if it's 500 000 12 years
from now it should be worth a million at
six percent
and what you said at six percent is in
five years
the the value of the house should be 676
give or take there you go okay
sounds good so upside i should be
looking at making six percent
average per year over the next five to
ten years
it depends on the marketplace but that
is a good overall level over time
if i get six percent i one if i did
three percent
and that's going to depend you know
sometimes condos will lag if you're
looking at a condo condos will
definitely be something that will
typically appreciate the reason why they
like well
they don't appeal to everyone it's not
as broad of an audience it's a little
bit more segmented audience and there's
more restrictions and
you're not going to get uh typically
you're not going to get as good
appreciation as you would if it was a
detached single family home
okay so number one fit for your family
timeline three to five years number two
is time horizon which we kind of talked
about number three is upside potential
number what's four number four is going
to be making sure you buy it right
okay so how does it compare um i wanna i
want you to compare it
cost per square foot as opposed to
looking at price
do cost per square foot for a similar
home and see if you're in the ballpark
and then by the way a template for that
like it should be around 200 bucks a
square foot
it has to be very location correct now
by the way those are all the tools that
we create for mortgage professionals to
help them do this in a second but on
their phone but the thing that that i
think is very
important for individuals who are
looking if they're going to make this
purchase
and they're going to find something that
is at least comparable
and they have to pay over then you look
back at one step
and you say okay what's my upside
potential does it pay for me to pay over
asking price
if in five years it's going to be worth
this and i'm paying that
i still get to make a lot of money so if
you're going to make an in the example
you said so it goes to 700 000
from let's say 500 in five years so five
years i make two hundred thousand
dollars
if i pay twenty thousand dollars over
asking price that seems like a good gig
okay that that's that's a reason but
it's knowing that you're gonna get that
six percent over the next five year
period and nobody knows that number
nobody knows what's going on nobody
knows but you can make educated guesses
and a lot of them are based on
demographics
look when we accurately call them are
based on demographics yes
so when we accurately called the bottom
of the housing market and we also
called we so this was really interesting
because when i was when i was on tv
talking about there's going to be
problems in the housing market i used to
get like a lot of hate mail what do you
mean you know i said don't take
mortgages with negative amortization
don't take interest only yeah
oh this product and we didn't like the
housing market i actually sold my
company because
we did not like the way the housing
market was and one of the main reasons
was you looked at demographics
so let's just take the demographics
today the median age of a first-time
home buyer is 33 years old
which means they were born in 1987 or
1988.
if you look at the birth rates from 33
years ago
what you'll discover is that 32
31 30 29 years ago the birth rates for
whatever reason
skyrocketed that tells us that in the
next four years there's going to be an
enormous
influx of first-time home buyers and
that is going to be similar to what
happened on boomers
that's exactly right well it's because
these 33 year olds are millennials
they're the kids
70s and in 80s
when we said we don't like the housing
market and remember it was still pretty
good in 2006 so we're a little bit early
right
but we looked at the demographics and we
saw that in 1973
there was a plunge in birth rates so we
knew the amount of first-time home
buyers coming to the market
was going to be significantly depleted
there was a reason for that
because in january of 1973 abortions
were legalized
birth rates plummet and 33 years later
you don't have people to buy homes at
the same time builders built the most
homes they ever put up nearly 2 million
homes that they built
so you had overage supply not enough
demand
prices were crashing too much liquidity
in the market people were looking for
where to put it
so what do they do they have to crank up
the volume so they took buyers who
really shouldn't have bought a home
fog up a mirror you can have a mortgage
and
just come no assets no no income no
asset no job no right exactly
580 fico scores what could go wrong
i mean really so what they did was they
cranked up the volume
issued a lot of mortgages and it wasn't
the mortgage lenders it was
wall street putting out this money
saying hey you got to fill these
commitments
so they just allow the regulations or
the compliance for those to be
very loose and what you had was you had
a big housing bubble that occurred
that's interesting abortion laws
affected real estate 30 years later 32
years later 33 years later what uh 2006.
if you're in any kind of business and
you're not looking at demographics you
really need to do that very okay so
let's go through it again so no
i asked the question what should a buyer
look at before buying a house
barry who's a three times a three-time
christopher ball award with zillow which
is who makes the most accurate
prediction of what's going to happen
with uh uh
uh a value value so you got fit your uh
family goals
what is it if you're buying this house
does it fit your goals that you want
with your family
time horizon number two upside potential
is number three which is a math
formula you can use six percent is
victory over five to ten years
we have that for every single zip code
we can tell you and then four is buy it
based on square feet if you're gonna use
any kind of comps around homes around
your area go based on square feet
what's number five what's your last one
i i think the last one has to be that it
has to fit within your budget
so and listen i'm not saying that this
just because it's listed as number five
doesn't mean for an individual it's not
as important but it has to be within
your budget because
do you want to have a home that's got
great upside this and that but you can
never go out to dinner again
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you